to drive one of london's famous black
cabs you need to be a special kind of
person
london's cabbies don't use gps but then
they don't need it
they have the knowledge
i have undertaken the stiffest
geographical test
that any
transport operative has to go through
probably anywhere in the world
it consists of memorizing straight line
routes across london you learn something
like 25 000 streets left this street
right this street forward this
roundabout lead by this exit probably a
hundred thousand points of interest
on average it takes four and a half
years to complete the knowledge and only
one in seven students passes
those expert navigators that do are
remarkable specimens they're even
studied by scientists
and while all our brains are excellent
at decoding our surroundings good design
makes navigating a whole lot easier in
complex places like cities
this is all part of a process called
wayfinding
wayfinding is about finding your way
while you're interacting with your
surroundings the environment can help us
or can hinder us the information that
you've got can be useful or it can be
absent from the roads we drive the paths
we walk to negotiating busy airports and
shopping malls carefully designed way
finding systems are everywhere but in a
world where gps is in all of our pockets
do we risk losing our innate ability to
find our way
[Music]
way funny is kind of
the the opposite of being lost so
when you know where you're going or you
work out how you go somewhere then you
are actually using the the process of
wayfinding it is innate in humans as
creatures we come from the savannah and
we always needed to know where our food
was where water was where the camp was
so
our ability to navigate is kind of
fundamental to survival
humans are spatial beings
our brains give us an internal compass
to help us understand and navigate
unfamiliar environments
neuroscientists talk about the cognitive
map
which is the map that we have in our in
our brain
it effectively works in the same way as
a as a regular map because it allows us
to retain a memory and allows us for
example to take shortcuts
research has found very specific types
of cells in our hippocampus
that fire in different locations within
our environment place cells cover our
environment with a firing pattern
that we believe helps support the idea
of a cognitive map and as in we have
this
not just a physical representation of
our environment that we can kind of see
but actually a neural representation of
cells that fire
in a pattern in our environment that
helps us reduce the cognitive demand
needed to actually travel from point a
to point b likewise grid cells are also
found in this region and they form a
hexadirectional
representation of a familiar learned
environment so for example as i'm
sitting in this room i would have a
grid-like pattern
um
of cells that fire that then kind of
move as i move around the room
as you kind of think of it as like
pointillism kind of the combination of
all of these different cells that fire
for different places and for different
directions that you're approaching
barriers and such in your environment
build up the idea that we have this
cognitive map
[Music]
despite the brilliance of our brains
it's still very easy to get lost in our
busy ever-changing cities
cities are very stressful places there's
a lot of noise tall buildings people
around london is notorious for being a
difficult place to find your way through
and people do get lost in it all the
time i couldn't find any of my landmarks
it provoked the
horror i was lost you know i really was
lost you want to end up
in a place and you end up in another one
so i was late for war because of that
london is a messy city compared to
something like new york
one reason is the sheer scale
it's a very big city it was not designed
as a city at the beginning a series of
different settlements
manhattan is a lot easier as a city to
navigate than london because of that
consistent uniform grid system when
people get lost they basically run out
of clues to help them orientate
themselves
point north
okay
is it that way
uh
the thames
[Laughter]
navigating in london is so difficult
that 44 of those walking above ground
actually use a map of the underground
london's tube
it's very accessible the tube map is an
excellent device for understanding
london's whole structure and how to
connect and use it across the city it's
a shorthand
it gives you a picture of the city it
gives you a confidence
but it's not a great device for walking
around the difficulty is when
people
use the tube map to navigate when they
get above ground
because it's not a reflection of how the
city is laid out
we found that there's a lot of people
getting lost there's a lot of people
who didn't travel places because they
didn't think they could when you look
down the street and it doesn't look very
interesting or whatever is at the end of
it isn't very visible
you will naturally think maybe i won't
go down there let's not adventure well
the next street could be full of
wonderful interesting bohemian stores
that you want to go and see but because
you can't see it you don't know it
exists and you don't go down there and
the city therefore is a quite dark place
until you get to know it and then you
know those little shortcuts you know
something is around the corner but that
takes time for you to build a mental map
and to understand it and have that
confidence
applied information group is a design
agency who specialize in fixing this
very problem they created a tool to help
people get around the city center
legible london
legible london is
london's walking system
it started really from the observation
that
walking around london you don't get a
lot of help in the last mile the sign
system is
designed around
answering four questions no more than
that the first question is where am i
so you'll see information at the top
giving you the village that you're in
and the area within that village and
there's a map with a large you are here
to kind of okay so this is going to help
me tell me where i am
second question that it answers is well
where is it so we don't know what you're
looking for and
and this is the reason why it evolved as
a mapping system rather than with lots
of fingerprints because on a mapping
system we can get between 200 and 250
locations on that map
the third question is well how do i get
there and that's why you see this very
careful selection of landmarks which are
highlighted that are designed to be
placed along routes so that you can see
that i need to go along here and that's
why we started to introduce 3d buildings
because we found just naming them and
saying there was a church here wasn't
doing enough and then the fourth
question well what else is around here
so that's why you had this wide area map
that goes out to five minutes with a lot
more detail because it actually tells
you that there are interesting streets
around the corner the oh i didn't know
there was another tube station there
[Music]
as you approached this
this sign with the map on it it's quite
obvious that i'm here the way in which
i'm facing and if you look ahead south
moulton street that's south morton
street
so immediately i haven't had to think
and i'm orienting myself
the map at the top here gives me more of
an idea of what's within 15 minutes so
if you can see the number of tube
stations there's about nine of them
there within a 15-minute walk and a lot
of people realize that these tube
stations are as close as that and it
gives you the basic directions in order
to get there using these pathways which
were decided very carefully and then as
you're traveling we'll be guiding you by
finding other ones of these signs along
the way
we also from research know that
remembering street names
is very hard to do the reason being is
that street names are quite abstract and
they don't create an image in your mind
and your memory works so much better
when you create an image
um you know one of those secrets of
learning people's names is as soon as
you meet somebody you meet a kevin just
think of kevin bacon and then when you
meet them next you think why am i
thinking kevin beck i know your name's
kevin that's how the brain works so
that's why street names are poor
we just ended up redacting taking things
out how can we make this as simple as
possible because there's so much
information on that map it's so detailed
it can become overwhelming very very
quickly
it takes a lot of iteration to get that
balance right to get all of these things
in play i think we went through about
293 different iterations to resolve the
whole design the colours on the map were
probably one of the hardest things to
try and resolve big learning there is
to try and reduce the number of colours
that you're using we came up with the
use of blue
it's a colour that works well in uk's
overcast skies
we wanted them to be like you can spot
them from a distance and that's where
the the idea of a yellow bar at the top
came from it was higher up it was kind
of yellow in the environment it kind of
speaks to about information and can be
very visible and all the research that
we did showed not by a huge factor but
the power of the transport for london's
typeface johnston the the kind of
respect that it had for giving me
transport information being part of the
transport system and using johnson
underground makes more logical sense
in the spears lab at university college
london neuroscientists sarah and chris
are running an experiment on cab driver
james
so the next thing we're gonna run is a
very exciting scam for us it's the high
resolution picture of your hippocampus
would you like to begin
on your way all right perfect
they're hoping to learn about how our
brains change by studying expert
wayfinders
we're taking a much more detailed look
at the cabbie hippocampus than has ever
been done before
it is helping us to learn
how the cabbie hippocampus grows
the task that we have taxi drivers
perform is very similar to the job that
they do on a daily basis the game will
begin again in a few seconds
with another 15 roots
we essentially have them do a route
planning task where we tell them a point
a to a point b
ask them to plan this route in their
head
and then simply ask them a yes or no
question would you take street x
and then they respond yes or no they
would take that street along the route
they planned in their head the design of
this task was developed to actually test
a mathematical theory of
how they might be able to plan over this
huge structure in state space that is
the 30 000 streets of london they can't
possibly just you know be planning
across all of the streets all of the
possible connections first of all that
would take
way too long and these taxi drivers plan
their route in about
three seconds
at least they say they do when you come
to the window tell them where you want
to go they think okay i know where to go
and then they take you there and
simply there has to be a way for them to
reduce this massive cognitive demand of
this it's actually interesting as we've
talked to a lot of taxi drivers now
they've informed us that you know the
most difficult routes for them are
actually the shortest routes the ones
that are kind of within a local area
because those routes are actually
kind of they have the least margin of
error there
they pretty much do actually have to
plan the entire route from street a to
street b whereas when they have a longer
journey they're able to more easily
compartmentalize that route into a
series of
global segments
london taxi drivers are this kind of
very famous example of adult plasticity
in the brain and specifically adult
plasticity in the hippocampus which is
the region that is one of the first to
be impacted by the onset of alzheimer's
disease and we're hoping that that will
give us a better understanding of
how this area grows
before
it's started to decline
and that will give us
one just a better understanding of the
hippocampus in general but then also you
know down the line whether or not
doing something like this and learning
the knowledge becoming a taxi driver
growing your hippocampus having this
adult plasticity whether you know that
gives you does it give you a buffer
does it help you
prevent alzheimer's disease those are
questions that we don't know the answers
to
while navigational skills are clearly
useful do the majority of us really need
them in a world where simple journey
planning can easily be done by apps on
our phones every piece of technology
comes with its own pros and cons right
and having satnav using google maps or
apple maps or whatever
it's it is great in the sense that it
does help people who you know might not
be a great navigator or you're visiting
a new place it can be very helpful in
that sense you're essentially reducing
the cognitive load for yourself by
offloading it to this app
but
in doing so you're
you're not training your brain
essentially so you're not going to learn
that route
we must definitely convince ourselves
that we can't figure it out we have a
cognitive block we often don't think we
can do something our ability to navigate
is kind of fundamental to survival so
while we think
and many people argue that gps is kind
of getting rid of that ability
everything that we've studied says it's
kind of like it's it's born with every
child and it's a matter of merely
exercising that muscle
if you're hoping to get there you'll
definitely get there if you're hoping to
train your brain and become a better
navigator
it's
probably not the best way to go
[Music]
smart design can encourage us to wayfind
and strengthen our natural navigational
skills while you probably shouldn't
delete those apps that use gps just yet
it might be worth traveling a part of
your next journey without it who knows
you might grow a hippocampus like james
my idea of fun on a weekend away
somewhere is to get myself lost
and then find my way out
so i will deliberately
find the back streets and then i'll work
out how to get back to where i want to
be and i'm pretty good at it
you